foretelling text messages The Silence of
the Lamb's inspiration bizarre tirades
and piano drops two and a half men's
ending isn't as simple as you think
and of course he's dead Walden receives
the text from Charlie which is a lengthy
rant against him this rant contains
plenty of strange comments including the
phrases bayonets of Truth an army of
Assassins and allusions to Charlie's
Tiger Blood many of these phrases are
taken almost verbatim from Commons
Charlie Sheen made following his
departure from Two and a Half Men the
bayonets of truthline is likely meant as
a parody of Sheen's live tour fastball
my violent torpedo of Truth slash defeat
is not an option announced shortly after
his contract termination with CBS the
army of Assassins he threatens Walden
with is a reference to Sheen's previous
comments on a media show where the actor
claimed the following there's a new
sheriff in town and he has an army of
Assassins the line about Charlie's tiger
blood is an obvious Riff on Sheen's now
Infamous interview with ABC News after
discussing his past use of alcohol and
drugs she instead I just have a
different Constitution I have a
different brain I have different heart I
got tiger Blood Man Charlie's text to
Walden calling him a troll may also be a
reference to Sheen's past comments about
Jon Cryer after his dismissal in which
he referred to Cryer as a troll among
other names for not defending him from
CBS and Chuck Laurie
in part two of the finale Alan and
Walden go to the police to ask for their
assistance while meeting with police
Lieutenant Wagner the two provide a
summary of the entire Series in a meta
dialogue after Walden underscores just
how dangerous Charlie's rage is Wagner
asks the duo if Charlie ever tried anger
management this leads Alan to quip yeah
but it didn't work this joke is a dig at
Charlie Sheen's FX series anger
management which he worked on after Two
and a Half Men the premise of the series
was meant as a somewhat self-aware
meditation on Sheen's own rage issues
with the actor playing a former baseball
player whose career comes to an end
because of his uncontrollable anger the
sitcom was Sheen's first acting role
after Two and a Half Men and was meant
as his return to TV after his followed
with Chuck Laurie while anger management
ran for a healthy two seasons it earned
mix to negative reviews from critics
some unfavorably compared it to Sheen's
previous sitcom role shortly after its
100th episode aired the show was
canceled by FX leading to Allen's joke
in two and a half men's final episode
at the start of of course he's dead rose
is shown preparing a meal and descending
into her basement where a large pit is
seen in the middle of the floor placing
the meal into a basket and luring it
into the hole she tells the Unseen
character who she refers to as it to eat
the meal she prepared and to change his
clothes of course it's revealed that
it's Charlie in the pit when Charlie
appears reluctant to do either of rose's
requests she threatens to spray him with
a large fire hose until he complies the
entire scene is meant as a direct parody
of the academy award-winning film The
Silence of the Lambs in that film the
serial killer antagonist known as
Buffalo Bill keeps his victims in a
large pit located in his basement very
much like Rose's own pit in Two and a
Half Men Buffalo Bill also takes to
addressing his victims with the
dehumanizing it and threatens to spray
them with a hose should they disobey him
it rubs the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again the influence
Silence of the Lambs has on the finale
doesn't stop there either during the
finales animated Flash sequence Rose has
seen transporting Charlie from Paris on
a metal Gurney with Charlie restrained
via a straight jacket and muzzle this is
the exact same manner that Anthony
Hopkins iconic serial killer Hannibal
Lecter is transported
halfway through the finale a montage
shows several women from Charlie's past
receiving personal apology letters and
large checks in the mail three of these
four women played larger roles earlier
in Two and a Half Men two of whom
Charlie even came dramatically close to
marrying in the series initial Seasons
during this Montage viewers see
Charlie's former girlfriends Mia Chelsea
and Dolores pasternik Mia was a ballet
teacher who Charlie fell in love with in
season 3 of Two and a Half Men and
became a regular romantic interest for
Charlie from Seasons five through seven
she was also his fiance for a short time
in season 3 although Charlie decided to
break off the wedding after Mia tried
kicking Alan and Jake out of the house
Chelsea was Charlie's girlfriend
throughout season six eventually
becoming his fiancee in season seven
their engagement was impacted by a
number of personal issues and side
romances on both of their parts
resulting in Chelsea breaking up with
Charlie in the end introduced in season
two Dolores pasternik was one of Jake's
teachers who Charlie similarly dated for
a short time the character went on to
appear again in season 6 and season 7
although she was played by a different
actor all three women were also featured
at Charlie's funeral service in the
opening moments of season 9. alongside
Charlie's past romantic interests
several Old Flames of both Alan and
Walden are also featured in of course
he's dead as they anxiously await
Charlie's Vengeance each of them dials
up some of their long-running
significant others for Alan this
includes ex-girlfriend Lindsay and his
two Ex-Wives Judith and candy for Walden
this includes ex-wife Bridget and
ex-girlfriend Zoe all of these women
played big roles during Two and a Half
Men before the events of the series
Judith and Allen maintained an unhappy
marriage with each other their
subsequent divorce caused Alan to move
into Charlie's beach house in the pilot
episode candy was one of Charlie's many
one-off girlfriends in season 3 who
later dated Alan becoming his second
wife soon after they divorced in season
4 with candy enjoying a successful
career as a television star Lindsay was
Allen's on-again off-again girlfriend
during the final few seasons of the
series reluctantly becoming engaged to
Alan after seeing the massive ring
Walden purchased on Allen's behalf
Bridget was Walden's wife prior to his
debut on the show divorcing him because
of his supposed immaturity however she
once again developed feelings for him
after the divorce was finalized after
the end of his marriage to Bridget
Walden then becomes attached to Zoe but
the two breakup when Zoe learns of
Walden's romance with rose in season 10.
along with the several sizable checks he
sends to his ex-girlfriends Charlie also
mails a check to Jake for 250 000 likely
Charlie giving Jake such a large amount
of money is meant to reflect his General
warm feelings towards his nephew much of
the earlier seasons of Two and a Half
Men find Charlie and Jake bonding in a
variety of pastimes together taking his
young nephew under his wing Charlie also
encouraged Jake to learn from his own
mistakes in life and avoid repeating
them as Jake Grew Older and became
increasingly distant from his father and
Uncle Charlie was seen to treat him less
warmly than he had in previous Seasons
still he admitted to harboring a fond
place for Jake a few times as the show
went on usually when he was inebriated
Charlie's tending Jake Money illustrates
that he still holds some love for his
nephew leaving their relationship on a
high note in the finale
okay you got me after receiving
Charlie's check for 250 000 Jake tells
Alan and Walden that he stopped at Las
Vegas before visiting them winning a
total of 2.5 million dollars from
playing craps in many ways this might
appear like a throwaway joke meant to
provide JK fitting epilogue for his
character but it also ties greatly to
his relationship with his uncle Charlie
as well in the early seasons of Two and
a Half Men Charlie was shown teaching
Jake various adult activities such as
poker from Jake watching his uncle play
Texas Hold him with his friends to the
two of them betting on sports games
together Charlie instructed Jake on all
the subtleties of gambling from an
incredibly young age as an adult it
makes sense that Jake learned to become
an effective enough Gambler to increase
his winnings from 250 000 to 2.5 million
dollars
one of the more unique aspects of of
course he's dead is the meta-aware
comedic style of the finale over the
course of the episode numerous jokes are
made about the show's content the
ludicrousness of its Central storyline
and its characters and the real-life
drama surrounding former star Charlie
Sheen's behavior in his personal life
there are even a handful of moments
where the actors address the audience
members regularly breaking the fourth
wall the creator of Two and a Half Men
Chuck Laurie has discussed the more
self-referential humor that the finale
employed with Entertainment Weekly there
Laurie said that the comedic style of of
course he's dead was meant mostly as a
way for the show to conclude in a
humorous way the showrunner said it was
our last swing at that bat why not throw
the rules out and do everything we can
imagine that might be funny and
acknowledging The Meta elements of the
show Lori also said that he felt the
show didn't warrant a more emotional
undertone as there was no Central
storyline imparted from the beginning of
the show that could be effectively
wrapped up with its conclusion yeah
right then the governor of codiforno
the final scene of Two and a Half Men
sees Charlie meeting his premature end
after piano crushes him while Charlie's
character here is played by a body
double and his face never revealed to
the camera it was initially planned for
Charlie Sheen to return to Two and a
Half Men as a special guest star for the
finale in an interview with ew Chuck
Lori said that he and CBS had tried
reaching out to Sheen to negotiate his
return for of course he is dead however
as Chuck Laurie said on his trademark
vanity card for the episode Sheen wanted
the show to end on a more cathartic note
he wanted to leave open the possibility
of a spin-off series starring himself
and John Pryor peddled the Harpers with
Lori wanting to maintain a more
light-hearted tone for the finale he
refused and the negotiations between
himself and Sheen soon fall apart for
Lori's vanity card for the episode the
initial plan was to have Charlie turn to
the camera and deliver a monologue about
the dangers of drug use over Time
Charlie's speech would devolve into a
bizarre tirade about how he was a Ninja
Warrior from Mars and was invincible
until his speech was cut short when a
piano crashes on top of it as it does in
the finished finale
Chuck Laurie's physical presence and his
subsequent death of the finale can be
eyebrow raising for some viewers however
confusing and meta Lori's appearance in
the show is though Lori has since
Justified his Cameo at the end of the
episode as well as elaborating on the
reasoning behind his on-screen demise
chatting to Entertainment Weekly Lori
said that the piano falling on both of
him and Charlie is meant as an
illustration of the rocky relationship
and the affected hat on the series in
Lori's eyes his Feud with Sheen
ultimately led to the show's steady
decline as Two and a Half Men went on
without Sheen there to headline the show
the two pianos falling on both of them
were therefore intended to be symbolic
with Lori saying it felt like the
funniest and most succinct way to end
the damn thing and dropping the second
piano also felt like an appropriate
response perhaps nobody wins but
hopefully we laughed along the way
foreign